well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Tuesday May 29 2008 teen
session in our series on
entrepreneurship in Asian high-tech
industries I'm Richard Dasher I direct
the US Asia Technology Management Center
here at Stanford we produced this series
and we want to thank our member
companies for support that allows us to
produce the series so from Bridgestone
Corporation brilliant hope incorporated
Mitsubishi Research Institute NEC and
also meet some a Khan University so it's
always kind of a shock to me that
suddenly here we are at the last session
of the series and when I think of all
the things we were able to talk about
and then all the things that we haven't
yet been able to talk about I realize
that you know we had a good series but
there's always more and I think that for
this last session the kind of more that
I want to talk about is the people who
are building bridges between startup
companies here and activities in Asia or
startup companies in Asia and activities
here and we also have three speakers
distinguished speakers who represent
different economies than we have been
able to introduce in the series so far
so sitting closest to me is MS Alisa Chu
and ELISA is the founder and curator
behind anchor Taiwan a soft landing
program that partners with governments
corporates and tech communities to
provide industry access and business
intelligence she came from Wall Street
and has a decade of experience at
investment banks and hedge funds she
also came to us from the University of
Toronto with a Master of Financial
Economics and UBC University of British
Columbia in with a BA Honours and
economics um she is a mentor at the
founder Institute and I'm delighted that
she'll be the first person to give us
comments sitting next to ELISA is mr.
Varon con otra and Varun is the managing
partner of Tec grind venture capital and
he's a co-founder of tech grind which is
an early-stage VC fund focusing on
building tech unicorns in Southeast Asia
he started his first business developing
inventory management solutions and he's
since launched ventures in technology
and consumer products finance and real
estate he served as a management company
to fortune 500 companies and he as a
graduate of the Georgia Institute of
Technology my old home state and
furthest away from me is mr. John moon
and John has extensive professional
experience in cross-border technology
management between South Korea and
Silicon Valley in areas that range from
information technology to clean tech he
was a senior director at a and B
property in Korea and managed a 125
million dollar REI T fund he was working
with the office of the Korean Consul
General in San Francisco he was helping
to connect Korean technology in the US
and he's going to talk to us about his
new venture 101 ventures so we'll ask
each panelist to give us ten minutes of
prepared remarks then I'll ask a
question or two to get discussion going
and then we go interactive oh I do have
one business item for students who are
registered for credit finish everything
all of your summaries by whatever day
and time is scheduled as the final exam
of the course that's critically
important because I have to turn grades
in on time so that you don't get hung up
before graduating so the scheduled exam
time of the course is the day to get the
last comment
and any kind of makeup work that you
have to get to me okay so thanks very
much for coming today
ELISA the floor is yours thank you thank
you doctor doctor - sure and hello
everybody
my name is ELISA as mentioned founder
and CEO of anchor Taiwan and today I'm
here to share a little bit about Taiwan
and about what I'm up to
so I think we have a very intelligent
group of people here tonight so I'm not
gonna go to a lot of basics but I do
want to point out something that maybe
some of you might not have realized
before so how many of you have been to
Taiwan here can you raise your hands
awesome Wow actually a pretty good
percentage here in this in this room so
you probably know that we are this tiny
little island by China with a lot of
nature beauties with 23 million of
people over there a lot of people might
not realize that actually even though in
terms of economy we are considered
pretty events and pretty developed but
if we were to dig into nominal GDP and
GDP adjusted for PPP which is parity
parity purchasing power parity
purchasing power parity there was
actually a big discrepancy so in the
world 2017 according to the data from
IMF this is the latest data basically
according to the nominal GDP we're about
30 in the world so not too bad but then
if we were to look at the number or just
it for PPP which is basically the number
of the money that you can actually
purchase goods which is usually used as
an indicator for standard of life or
quality of life then we're actually top
20 in the world so this is actually
something for you to bear a mite because
this will be actually pretty important
when it comes to decision to hire people
or you know decisions who potentially
start a business over there so in
nominal like USD terms that's basically
about 20,000 25,000 versus 50,000 kind
of like difference and you might not
realize which brands comes from Taiwan
because we're known to be very good at
making stuff behind the scene
we're actually in your daily life so I
don't know how many logos you can
actually recognize from these slides
actually can you shout out anything that
you can recognize a soos yes me a sir
the link anything else box tongue well
well okay we have someone who knows why
um so yes yes yes yes so basically we do
play a very important role especially in
hardware manufacturing in the world like
I'm sure for example a lot of people
might not know that but if you take cow
training the LED lights actually above
the track is manufactured by light on
50% of smart street lights in the u.s.
manufacturer manufactured by lion
Foxconn of course the biggest consumer
electronics manufacturer in the world
there are apples biggest manufacturing
partner so I guess now we have all agree
that Taiwan actually plays a pretty
important role in hardware this is
basically part of our heritage but
what's going on over there in recent
years apart from Hardware about a month
ago there is this article on Forbes
about why Google IBM and Microsoft are
all expanding in Taiwan this year so
Google basically in case you haven't
realized now actually has the biggest
engineering sites in Asia in Taiwan
after their acquisition of HTC in
addition to that they were actually
hiring more than 300 people and training
5,000 students especially in AI in
Taiwan this year IBM Microsoft they're
all spending millions of dollars
building R&D labs cloud research labs
and hiring hundreds of people over there
so where are they they're actually the
hiring manager from Google there is a
quote from her that the most rewarding
acquisition through that deal with HTC
HTC is the expansion of the talent pool
a lot of people are actually in Taiwan
to seek for readily kind of like easily
trainable talent and this is actually
very important with the hardware
heritage which is related to what I'm
going to point out now so I
currently all of the buzzwords in
technology crypto mining black chain AI
autonomous driving
you know like big data you name it all
this has one common denominator they all
requires massive processing power and
this is different from you know 10 or 20
years ago when Silicon Valley were after
that initial silicon boom you know that
basically with Internet company uber
Airbnb Facebook Google the huge
difference is that now the revolution
requires more than just writing codes
you actually do need hardware to be a
part of this equation in order to
actually make the next revolution and
guess where we have all this we have the
talents who knows how to work around
hardware and actually in march taiwan's
export actually rose by almost 17
percent because of this huge boom and
demand in crypto mining-related and AI
autonomous driving related demand in
chips in supercomputer so we're actually
seeing even the major startup
accelerators in taiwan at works say for
example and taiwan decelerator both of
them are very good friends of ankor
Taiwan there are repositioning sell
themselves focusing now purely on deep
tech kind of companies so mainly in AI
and blockchain there's actually a very
important and very interesting trend to
see so why am I here born raised in
Taiwan but been to a lot of places in
the world but why Silicon Valley so here
how many people do you recognize
actually on this slides - all right
what's the common denominator of these
people entrepreneurs yes anything else
Stanford maybe some of them yeah but
okay they all share Taiwanese roots in
case you haven't realized that ginseng
Hwang Bora born in Taiwan and I think he
came here when he was like 12 like
basically young students
either came here as a young student or
they were raised by taiwanese parents so
they all have roots in taiwan and this
is actually a very important train
because now the second or third
generation of this taiwanese
entrepreneurs there is success basically
can easily be translated into mentorship
and capital for entrepreneurs and
founders with taiwanese link because
naturally after they're successful
they're thinking about how to give back
they want to do more they want to
explore their roots in taiwan we're
seeing say for example a media there AI
initiatives with the Taiwanese
government and a lot of you know those
people
in the previous lights they'd be in
taiwan at conferences talking to young
entrepreneurs so this is actually
something very important to leverage on
and i guess you know i will the next two
speakers and also the fact that you're
here we probably don't need to convince
you that there are a lot of great
opportunities in Asia I would argue that
a lot of entrepreneurs here of course
Asian Americans but even if you're not
Asian because of this natural select
connection with Asian Americans here you
actually have an unfair advantage if you
want to conquer the Asian markets
because you probably chances are you
have some sort of connections over there
that can basically help you find the
right manufacturers or basically find
the right partners over there so a lot
of people that have come across here
especially if they have some sort of
embedded link with Asia now there are
saying the opportunities not just in
China but also in Southeast Asia and all
that they are thinking this is our time
how do we actually leverage the market
intelligence and branding capacity know
that here in the States
while having Asia as the cradle for
talents and all that for the success for
their business so and of course here
being in Silicon Valley we get to beat
of the ecosystem builders from around
the world which is really amazing so
what exactly is anchor Taiwan these
organizations that we started from 2017
essentially it's a platform for
world-class professionals and
entrepreneurs to grow experience and
succeed in Asia and subsidy we do it
through a 30 day residency program to
provide very
the industry access as well as culture
and markets immersion so we select
people from around the world Silicon
Valley is a very important base because
I have a base in San Francisco but we
also have friends from Europe from
Africa basically they all spend 30 days
on the ground leaving and working like a
local with daily activities with the
loans worksite workshops Tech Talks and
all that in Taiwan to actually gain that
actual local intelligence we have
founders from 500 startups Y
Combinator's and some of the top tech
companies from around the world so we
essentially are providing ecosystem as a
service because we are connected with
local governments corporates tech
communities universities so what we are
trying to do is through 30 days of
immersion we prepare the professionals
or entrepreneurs who are interested in
the Asian markets with the connections
resources and the tools that they need
in order to be successful we partner
with a lot of local ecosystems for our
events and workshops and these are some
of our examples if you're interested you
can actually go onto our website for
more organization we do a lot of events
for the sake of one introducing our
members to and integrate them with the
local communities and we also foster a
lot of communications so basically
what's going on in Silicon Valley versus
what's going on in Asia let's put the
people together let them talk let them
inspire each other let them have the
opportunities to actually collaborate so
we have already got our members who met
their co-founders or business partners
and then ended up moving to Taiwan to
start a new business or you know like
people who actually started
collaborating and hiring people in
Taiwan to leverage on the resources over
there so that's why we do all these are
actually our actual pictures from our
actual events that we have done from
2017 we have done basically right now
almost 20 events from both most of them
in Taiwan some of them here we have
Oregon about 1,500 people who have gone
through our events so this is us we have
basically I'm flying out literally after
the
tonight because we have a cohort coming
up in June and then the next two will be
in September and November specifically
I'm very excited that we are going to
actually have two Hardware innovation
tours this June so if you're interested
in knowing about how to deal with
manufacturers how to actually tackle the
supply chain we're going to have actual
training sessions as well as factory
tours to actually educate you about that
we're also very excited that we just
partner up with impact hub to have
mission-driven type of entrepreneurs and
help them with their access and
knowledge when it comes to circular
economy sustainability over there in
Asia so as me ELISA you can find me at
ELISA at anchor Taiwan calm feel free to
follow us on our social media if you
want to find out what we're up to thank
you okay ELISA thank you very much
thanks yeah why don't we trade places if
you'll go down to the end and Arun come
up here well I'm changing slides though
I do have a question for you ELISA it
used to be that traditionally the
approach to international business was
that you should grow your domestic
market until you've got enough funds to
really support overseas operations why
is it different now I mean because what
you're talking about are not companies
that already have 50 million dollars a
year in sales right I mean these are
companies that are really still
early-stage startups right that's
correct I would say it's it's still very
important to focus for entrepreneurs so
basically for our members usually either
they're at the early stage so they're
still exploring basically it is
important to focus on your home market
our argue like somewhere that you're
most familiar with because it's already
so hard to build a company it doesn't
make sense for you to basically spread
yourself too thin however because of the
global landscape in entrepreneurship and
in you know basically globalization I
always say any entrepreneur you should
actually start thinking about how to go
global from day one you don't
necessarily need to execute that right
away but you have to bake that into the
equation you have to know as an
entrepreneur where to go for the best
talent the most quality the best
partners in whichever secretary that
you're in so either come
we have a lot of members who come at the
early stage when there may be you know
like exploring an idea or MEP but they
want to have the right understanding and
resources and network in Asia in case
later on they want to get into that
markets okay thank you welcome back
there are some more questions I'm sure
that we can talk about doing during the
Q&A session Varun the floor is yours hi
so I'll spend a few minutes a kind of
broke up the presentation the two pieces
will talk about Southeast Asia as a
market and then I'll spend the back half
talk about tech grind the incubator side
and the venture capital side and so my
business partner frame who really spend
a lot of time in Southeast Asia
Randee incubator along with our team
there could join us today so but I'll go
over some of the key components of what
we've built there and and talk about
what we're doing with the venture fund
which is what primarily I'm involved
with here in the States
yeah okay so how many people here know
about the ASEAN region okay very good so
for the rest so so just quick history so
ASEAN is the Association of Southeast
Asian Nations it was formed back in 1967
so the five countries in Southeast Asia
came along said well we're gonna operate
and like a mini EU if you will open up
trade open up our borders that people
move around and now there are ten
countries in the as part of the
membership in ASEAN what's really
interesting and why I love this slide is
because you know where we've drawn this
circle gives you an idea if you look at
you know there's India 1.3 billion
people 1.6 billion in China was 650
million in ASEAN
you know that's but half half of the
world population lives inside the circle
I mean it's it's it's amazing when you
pause and really think about that
because when you think about consumerism
and you know how ripe this market is for
not just disruption
the technology side were more focused
but also you know in terms of online
media in terms of gaming you know you
look at the OTT space you know there's
huge amounts of disruption going on in
in Southeast Asia now Southeast Asia's
is the third largest growing economy
after China and India four million
people in Southeast Asia coming online
every single month so what's happened
there is where they had little to no
idea that access they've sort of
leapfrog to having mobile phone access
right so and then half of that almost
half of the people per second of the
population is under the age of 30 so now
you have young people you know with
mobile technology that have exposure you
know through that technology to the West
Western Way they're they're disrupting
you know the existing industries there
so you know just a huge mental shift and
I'm not saying they're not challenges
there's you know there's plenty but
overall we look at the growth picture
the ASEAN region and the arbitrage that
exists between where they are and where
we are is tremendous is massive so they
have a long way to go and you know they
can do that with you know win behind
their sails in terms of having that
technological power to be able to to be
able to do that so so if you look at if
you visit the us-asean Business Council
website they're in Washington DC and
their sole purpose is to increase the
relationship between the United States
and the ASEAN region you know the the
projection of there
and since we're focused on the digital
side the technology side I'll kind of
speak to that but expected to grow over
five times by 2025 now Google did some
research with Temasek a couple years ago
and they came back last year and revised
their numbers because of the growth
that's happening in the region is even
faster that what what they had studied
and projected so they're obviously
actively looking in the region Amazon
you know Alibaba
from China is looking looking in the
region so a lot of a lot of inter
in the tech economy in Southeast Asia so
so ASEAN you know right up their growth
wise GDP per capita is at the cusp of
what's called this S curve this is
there's a sigmoid function in
mathematics which is used to represent
demographic growth and if you study the
s-curve you'll see that there's a point
in that s curve where the trajectory of
growth just goes exponential so that if
you map that it's about 3,500 to 4,000
dollars of GDP per capita and we're
right at that at that cusp so let's talk
about why that's happening so you know
if you look at if you look at disposable
income if you look at the growth in the
middle class you know these these young
people in the region and you know this
is also happening I mean everywhere else
else in Asia
there's by 2030 4 billion people are
expected to enter this to be part of
this middle class so when you look at we
talk about consumers and before you know
what are these people spending spending
their money on right so a lot of it is
in the digital space because it's so new
as an entrant to the market so you know
sixteen hundred sixteen dollars two
hundred hours of disposable income per
day which their parents grandparents
didn't have what they want to do they
want to buy the first thing they want to
do is if actually buy a mobile phone
right they want to be connected they
want to be on Facebook so if you look at
Thailand for example where our
incubators based the Thailand has
seventy five percent penetration of
Facebook compare that to the u.s. it's
about fifty eight sixty percent they
spend four hours a day online four hours
a day just this amazing so so you know
if you're a start-up here looking to
expand I mean this is a perfect perfect
reason you know to look into you know if
you're a VC fund or if you're an angel
investor you know you're looking to
deploy capital you know if you compare
the overall returns in the equity market
in the von Maur
it's you look at Jeremy Grantham who
runs GMO the fund their projections over
the next seven to ten years the returns
here in the United States are are
negative the growth the real growth is
coming from Asia and you know
specifically Southeast Asia
now we don't hear much about Southeast
Asia yet but I would argue that in the
next 5-10 years we're gonna we're gonna
start getting more and more you know
China wasn't as much in the news here
the United States ten years ago that's
changed China takes up all the news now
Southeast Asia not so much yet you know
we're still in the early stages you know
going up that s-curve but we're
definitely getting there to that tipping
point so talk we'll talk a little bit
about the problems in the tech sector
there but let me actually go to this
slide so I'll talk a little bit about
tech right so so tech rind when in the
region five years ago and you know we
saw this saw this issue there we saw
that there was really no ecosystem in
the region helping founders locals there
start companies right so we said okay so
so we launched you know we've got five
different companies operating the region
but the first one that was launched was
a tech writing hub so we started
bringing people together hosting events
weekly monthly you know now that we do
monthly events quarterly events annual
events just to get people excited about
technology and let them know that we
have presence from the West all of us in
my partner's you know we're all
entrepreneurs ourself bringing that
knowledge local to the community over
there helping them start companies so we
started with tech writing hub we have a
co-working space over there to allow for
entrepreneurs to get together and
congregate and work we have an angel
syndicate where we teach angel investors
how to be angel investors we do a
weekend-long workshop we have we have a
VC fund now we're working on to bring
capital from the west from the United
States here into the region and do
follow-on funding
in Southeast Asia so so as we incubate
companies so there's when the incubator
first started about two and a half years
ago we had 900 startups that applied we
accepted 40 into the program there's 21
companies in the portfolio right now
nine of them are ready for follow-on
funding ready to graduate so it's the
longest-running incubator in the region
it runs 18 months and we joined them as
co-founders and hand hold on to the
process of of starting a tech company
especially you know if you're brand new
you've you know you have an interesting
idea because if you look at the region a
lot of the basic technological problems
have not been solved yet you know you
look at payment solutions you shouldn't
have to go to 7-eleven to pay your
electric bill I mean you know we're
we're in the 21st century here so so so
that's what I was talking about when I
when I said the arbitrage opportunities
is tremendous in the region little to no
competition right now very few
participation because we're early on so
the opportunity to scale and grow with
the right mentorship with the right
model business business plan that's the
team you know and you've got you've got
tremendous room to grow so you know just
to give you guys another number I mean
you know five years ago there were zero
technicans in Southeast Asia now there's
seven seven companies worth over a
billion and we're just getting started
so so there's definitely opportunity a
lot of room for growth so so talking
about more about tech right so you know
we run the incubator we we join them as
co-founders we run psychometric
assessment on the founders just to see
if they're crazy enough to to start
start a tech startup over there right
and we teach them you know different
aspects of building a company and then
as they graduate as a company's mature
the VC fund the plan of the VC fund is
to help to follow on funding you know
now that the model is proven this
companies are off the ground and expand
that that model and do more investments
in the region and more successful proven
and
he's there so so so let me go back to
you know kind of quickly talk about what
are some of the issues so you know so
you know great region for girl it's a
lot of room for growth but the problem
there's of course lack of knowledge
right the minds of there is where their
parents grandparents you know worked in
industries where you know you took on a
job and you kind of work for 30 40 years
and you know now here we are you know a
younger generation bringing in this
whole concept of disruption and fail and
keep failing and fail fast and you know
that's that that's hard for people to
grasp right so so you definitely you
know cultural mindset takes a while to
while the change but with existing
unicorns in the region now that helps
validate that yes you know there here it
is another avenue to do that you know
now the another reason being you know
not enough mentors not enough people
with this mentality from the West you
know in the region or you know people's
the practices there are very traditional
so corruption you know not another big
big hindrance just generally in Asia
lack of investment capital you know so
there were seven billion dollars
deployed in in VC funds last year which
is double from the year before 2016 was
three-and-a-half billion so the numbers
are you know we're still early stage we
deploy about 20-30 billion here in the
United States and a quarter so so
there's there's definitely opportunities
so so tech Ryan what we did was we said
okay so we when we first started started
the program
you know made our mistakes and through
failure we learned you know there's a
lot more hand-holding that's needed so
and you know what we are very hands-on
with our startups as we incubate them so
said okay can we bring our our knowledge
our experience our skillset join them as
co-founders and work with them in
developing these companies and really
build that mini Silicon value if you
will through this Y Combinator type
model
keep the system independent of
government influence so it's run
completely independent it's all private
funded you know same thing on the on the
angel investment side and you know turn
these startups that we've incubated into
into success stories so now that we've
done that you know the model is proven
we're ready to scale that you know
through the VC funding so that's that's
tank right that's great Barney thank you
so before you before you change see ya
so you're you've been doing the
incubator for two and a half years
already and I'm guessing it's an 18 to
24 month kind of period right so are you
on your second set mostly are you kind
of rolling over and doing like eight or
eight companies a year or how do you do
this yeah so that's that's kind of where
the nine companies that are mature
enough to exit because one thing we
learned is and you know we talked about
kind of expanding that even longer than
24 months and you know we're not I mean
clicking companies out gonna give them
enough time you know to develop their
product to mature and knowing that we're
the region is and you know the kind of
guys that they need the plan is to to
have them exist yeah so the second round
would be starting so now one thing that
we've also added here back in and the
first quarter is an eight-week
accelerator program which is a pre
incubation solution which is takes no
equity in the startups is completely
free and it's just it's just to
encourage more founders to join and
learn and you know they learn about
marketing they learn about sales product
development the engineering side of
things how to do a product market fit
how to build an MVP how to pivot and and
then sort of modify them and into the
incubator so yeah so the space is
located in Bangkok but you're focusing
on five ASEAN countries possibly asean
connected right now I think a lot of
people sort of see ASEAN is kind of
still more
virtual than the EU is because there's
no common currency you know it really is
10 or 11 very different country right
right but yet people can come from any
of these five countries and be resident
in Bangkok for the program the was so
yeah we you know most of our founders
that we meet you know they either come
to us with concepts with ideas you know
to our events so you know we've cast a
pretty wide net to the hub which has
been operating for a while now we've had
over 20,000 people go through our events
so we a lot of times meet founders you
know companies that they haven't formed
yet and they're you know in the ideation
stage so well yeah we definitely
encourage people to come you know
programs in there and then I mean they
can live I mean you know reasonably
nearby we know uh-huh so we can you know
continue to work work remotely in and
mentor them okay yeah that's great why
don't we do the musical chairs yeah so
our comments now oops here we go what
happened here it didn't like me pulling
the cord our final set of covenants is
from mr. John moon more chairs so thank
you for having me here doctor - and a
loss of screen right now that's oh we
lost the screen hold on this this is
probably now I understand why it didn't
was unhappy I'm in Rangoon yep there we
go okay okay yeah was sorry about that
no problem happen all the time hor you
know just say international so hi
everyone my name is John I'm a CEO of SV
101 SP 101 is a tech accelerator
focusing on Koreans
crane innovative and startup helping
those companies coming to Silicon Valley
at the same time we are helping Silicon
Valley companies you know just
connecting and bridging into the career
market and then our interest of in our
industry technology industry our IT ICT
and AI robotics and destroy Earth and a
lvl so if you are working on these
domains we are definitely bringing those
guys and open the dialogue with those
people okay
SP 101 constantly building a platform
breaching the the Korean startups care
to the Silicon Valley and then it this
is kind of critical at the moment
because last four five years Korean
government government spent tremendous
money kind of cultivating fortunately
startup and and then enterpreneurship in
Korea and now with tremendous amount of
effort and then many injecting to this
building up the ecosystem in Korea it is
about time we can bring more Korea
starts get into the global marketplace
at the same time we are also helping the
area the Silicon Valley startups getting
to the Korean market and then there is a
mutual or bilateral or business
exchanges can be placed in terms of
cultivating the other and to premiership
in both regions so we have worked hard
last two years tested our the spo11 tech
accelerating platform which is consists
of preparation and the acceleration and
the market access and growth so we laid
off like a one week or two week
intensive courses in Korea court
preparation class or training workshops
and there we bring those guys in to
Silicon Valley for three months and then
try to validate or evaluate test out
their product and solutions and then we
are helping those guys localization in
the Silicon Valley or in the global
marketplace
why we're doing that because we are kind
of providing a constant support and
promotion not only focus in the Silicon
Valley at the same time we're targeted
in different countries like China and
other European country so I'll give you
color on you the portrait of Korean too
poo-ish since the last 15 years starting
2004 2008 Korean the economy growth rate
was four to five percent annually and
this was based on the strong export and
the internal consumption but getting
into the 2009 to 2012 right after the
global financial crisis Korea is
severely devastated by the tremendous
unemployment rate direct hit a record
high and then there they were new or no
new jobs for the newly graduated college
students so that situation continued
until 2012 so seeing these problems
Korean government there is a plan to sub
cultivating and to prune your
entrepreneurship and then building up
this startup ecosystem pledging like a
thirty three billion dollars over five
years to you know just provide a startup
ecosystem and infrastructures for
startups and then as a result of that
there are there O'War about 17 Korean
innovation centers throughout the Korea
so that each the innovation centers
focus in different industry vertical now
when you say innovation center are you
talking about something that's rather
large like Silicon Valley are you
talking about a building or a
neighborhood in the town
yes it's combined of the buildings
and tying up with the universities and
local angel investors and visas that is
the developing the major metro area
throughout Korea so so has its own you
know the in innovation centers and then
Busan always this is the same but they
have focusing in a different industry
and the technology so as you know there
is a new Korea the Korea elected new
president and then mr. moon jae-in and
then his administration I realized that
the previous government effort is not
you know just effective and that too
much broad you know the supporting
programs so they are kind of focus on to
helping the startup working along with
small and mid-sized companies so that
they can you know just a collaborating
on their you know just a development
technology R&D those kind of stuff the
behind this scene why this the the new
Korean government try to kind of put
this initiative in place because they're
trying to minimize the the government
interference all the starter because
ecosystem so that they are heading more
50 that the startup accelerator
throughout this year so currently there
is only 50 but government is a lot more
and I just globally experienced business
professionals come to Silicon Valley out
and coming to Korea and then incorporate
the global accelerator in Korea market
also there the other thing is that that
I'd like to highlight is starting this
year first quarter of 2018 Korean
government's allow the Korean ha you
know just a fund going abroad into the
different countries or different regions
so meaning is that preview until 2017
the government not allow the Korean man
you go outside Korea so starting this
year there is a humongous high you know
just
inquiries that are getting from the
Korean base venture capital or air peas
in GPS you know just trying to tackle
along the opportunities making they're
creating their investment funds in
Silicon Valley so that they can start
investing onto the new technology or
innovative startups in the valley so
this is kind of overall a picture of the
Koreas texta startup ecosystem there's a
government comes in and there is a
co-working space available and then
there is a accelerator domestic Korean
accelerators and then global
accelerators comes in I think there is a
spark labs and then 500 startups already
came into a Korean market and then the
Korean the funding mechanism has been
you know just evolved so that there are
kind of sit around as series around
investors and in one stage and then
followed by the series B and gross fund
capital or fund available so this is
entire kind of news that they are
creating the the entire startup
cultivating ecosystem in Korea as of
today so like I said before there is a
17 Korea innovation centers available if
you are willing to tackle all the
particular industry or technology
verticals you can just go to some places
like if you're working in the Samsung
you have to go for the world the Samsung
Electronics is right and if you're
working with the auto the Hyundai auto
are early or Kia automobiles you gotta
go this place so they can help you from
the from the ground and then these are
the mainly five categories that you will
get the government support but I don't
want to just kinda you know
I mean there is a like a new into
premier support text out of support and
then global expansion support and female
interpreter also get the support but
moreover I'd like to highlight that a
restart of Support Package because
previous time you know just the most of
the Korean entrepreneurs got failed and
that you're done that is up I think as
far as I know most of the Asian culture
so once you failed you're not able to
start restart on your program or
startups or get hired so basically
you're stuck in the middle do not think
okay that one was a tinker starting
until the two thousand fifteen or
sixteen but government see this problem
so cultivating the kind of constant you
know just a support for the
entrepreneurs continue working on their
partner or startups they are providing
this restart of package for the
entrepreneurs who have failed first time
so however there is some challenges
overall still exist in the trailer
market right now so the one thing that I
like like to highlight is the Korean
government has a too much of regulations
incorporating start of accelerator
because this is the government
registration program if you like to come
to Korea and then incorporate the
incorporate the startup accelerator you
got a register under government system
so also another drawback is the the
government is monitoring all your
activities throughout and all the
accelerators in the Korean market right
now so that is kind of you know just
having a challenging right now so but
throughout this year or next year the
government will be able to kind of lower
the barriers or easy on the registration
on startup accelerators and then once
you I mean another hurdle is
the if the startup or at the premiere
got government funding they have to have
the kind of you know just submitted a
necessary amount of documents to the
government agency so that is a burden
for the startups because they have to
focus more into their product and then
propel the companies and then also this
is a me and Amanda Truitt they have to
they have to attend a mandatory seminars
and the mentoring sessions so that is
another one because you know just the
government always call upon to attend
this is magnitude you got to attend this
event and then then to that event so
that's that that's totally unnecessary
no and there what's that mean so
government funded a lot of money into
their startups so they are kind of
rolling out too heavy due diligence
annually so at the end of year in
December timeframe you have have have to
providing a lot of documents for the
government hard audit things and still
even though governments and then
creating you know just a lot of people
is kind of focusing warranted a global
audience just a promotion platform but
the Korea does need a lot of you know
just global business experience people
coming to Korea helped in Korean
startups because we are a very lack of
those experience it'll come down the or
global marketplace experience the
business professionals in Korea mark as
of today so very helpful so we are the
Korea shoe are inviting more experts and
the professionals investors coming to
Korea helping the Korean startups and
then to prune your ecosystem John before
you go further I want to ask you why is
the government regulating accelerators
and startups like this are they
concerned about fraud or is it because
there is tax money and just about
everything or yes that's the real issue
yeah so the once you just register your
solar entity through the government
system the the accelerator can be
realized the tax incentives on there are
capital
earnings capital gaining so and they're
also the startups also getting around
you know government support and grants
so they are heavily regulated at the
moment as of today but will be easy on
you know just moving forward okay so and
another one is if you saw a start-up in
Korea there is always hard to find a
top-notch talented people in Korea
because most of the creative still who
abroad are studied abroad there are
trying to remain in that particular
region for instance Silicon Valley if
any of the crash didn't study in
Stanford they're now willing to go back
to Korea right and so are we always even
though we have a great infrastructure we
have great programs but most of the top
talented people when it's not going to
you know just coming back to North Korea
and then they'll kind of participate
into this kind of fostering program and
then this is more toward the latter part
of the startup our business but the
Korean successful Korean business in
Korea are always having a trouble or
problem facing a business of flipping
when they just come into Silicon Valley
so meaning is that whether they just
have a kind of you know just a
tremendous success in Korea and they try
to come to Silicon Valley and then there
is a steel you know just tax imposed by
the government as a thinking between 30
to 35% of on your test are capital gain
taxes so this is a the challenge at the
moment for the Korean startups and then
just kind of briefly mentioned about
some of the vanishing cream right now so
like I say they the government pour a
lot of money to kinda you know just
building a startup ecosystem and then
can the communities they they build the
several startup campuses and innovation
centers providing all-in-one services so
if I want to I start my own business and
then you know just nothing the doorstep
in this particular Center and they will
provide everything okay
and then also the government the
government provided a free co-working
spaces along with the free use of ten
laps so you know charges at all okay so
and then also there is so many different
types of the premiership workshops
training programs and also the local
even local government and as locals the
Korea startup accelerator is always you
know just providing this type of
learning program you know throughout
annually and then to find out the other
one that are like haha that I'd like to
highlight it's a funding availability in
Korea right now so there's there is a
tons of money available for your you
know how during the project in Korea
also there is a tons of money available
for your you know just whole startup you
know just program I mean the business
that the tips program it is one of the
highlight that are like I mentioned the
technology in create a program for
startup is they are matching fund so
it's a 1 to 9 I think so and then also
the the Korean government kind of
cultivating angel investors and your
groups in Korea so that they are and I
didn't get to access and gel and going
into the financial investors like a
visas and then getting into the kaha CVC
so with this kind of you know just
effort Korea is now getting attention
from global investors so many of the
financial Buster's has the venture
capital investors investing on the
Korean companies like a Sequoia Capital
investing Kupang and then
formation 8 invested in the other mobile
and then good water capital investing
minibox this is more like a Silicon
Valley venture capital invest
in Korean companies and their strategy
investment there is an Intel investing
acquire Allah works and then Goldman
Sachs investment parameter this is Auto
food delivery service and then Lafayette
or Rakatan part of it which is the
Korean drama video streaming services I
think this is I think this is we need to
move on pretty quick yeah yeah so this
is about that my last page oh yeah yeah
so that I can kind of guide you the
portrait of this the Korean startup
ecosystem there's entrepreneurship as of
today but starting this year there will
be more Korean startups that will come
to Silicon Valley tackle along the
harder more opportunities or you know
just a starting on you know just
adapting their localization and offer
their business operation and the value
so does about me okay thanks very much
John the problem so we've got Taiwan
where what you're doing ELISA is to
bring startups from all over into Taiwan
for some training and maybe acquisition
of talent and you know setting up
business relationships barloon what
you're doing is really inside Asia
getting people around ASEAN into a
center and helping them grow inside
ASEAN and John what you're doing is
getting Korean startup companies to come
over here all of this involves
cross-border
mmm-hmm and so I'm curious how the
programs a lot of what you described is
kind of okay this is accelerator 101
right you learn how to write a business
plan you get introduced to people you do
various things what are the distinctive
things you have to do to localize your
services for the startup companies
you're trying to reach so maybe maybe we
should go with ELISA first so something
that's different than it just why not
just do it at Y Combinator that's a very
great question
they actually probably won fundamentally
what's the core of entrepreneurship I
argue that a lot of that is about
empathy it's about the ability of
putting yourself in someone's shoes to
solve an issue or a problem and I would
argue that one of the best benefits of
getting to a place outside of your
comfort zone is that it basically seems
stimulates your ability of doing that
the understanding the cultural
competency actually is a very important
element of whatever business that you're
a building so I would say in terms of
localization before I go into the
details in terms of what we actually do
on the ground for the people in our
program the benefit of putting yourself
there throwing yourself into a place
that maybe you don't speak the language
you don't understand the culture and all
that if you have any interest of getting
into that markets or the markets around
there I would say if I were you the
first thing I would do is to get myself
there because you need to understand the
consumer habits you need to understand
what they like and you can read all
about this from here but the reality is
that you are now gonna get that
firsthand actual experience unless you
actually get yourself there yeah I think
that's a good point so you've actually
spent some time in Asia and see how
people use smartphones there yeah you
really don't get a sense of what it's
like from this side of the Pacific Lori
what about your localization yeah so I
would you know answer that this way I
mean the reason why we can't do it at Y
Combinator is because the problems that
exist here you know with the level of
maturity we've had the growth we have
had over the last 40 50 years of doing
this are very different from what they
are in Asia right or you know Southeast
Asia specifically so you know in order
to do that I 100% agree I mean which is
why our focus on the incubator side is
to help entrepreneurs from the ground up
build their startups in the region and
we're focused on five countries a focus
on Thailand Indonesia Philippines
Malaysia and Vietnam
so let me nail down into this a little
bit more
is the model of company startup
development that you're talking about
different from the model that every
everybody knows here in Silicon Valley
I mean the differences are that it's a
model that's not trying to copy the West
or try to be like a Y Combinator or a
Silicon Valley but that the model is to
allow for the local young population or
you know people who have been you know
in an industry and see a problem now
have another Avenue right that where
they want they want to find a solution
to a problem that they're having maybe
in their job or you know people coming
out of college having worked for a few
years get together with their friends
they want to they want to you know solve
problems so to me a big reason for
entrepreneurship is value addition I
mean that's how that's how I you know
not just in business but live my life as
well as you know where can I and how can
I have continued to add value right so
that what that's what's critical so
aligning with those entrepreneurs on the
incubator side and then on the VC side
with those that pool of investors is
very important you've got to know your
why you've got to understand you know
the the challenges behind starting
companies and failing which inevitably
will happen so we encourage that as much
upfront as you can because you have to
go through those cycles because the
learning is really on the other side so
until you start taking those steps and
crawling and you know then eventually
walk and run and you know and we'll help
you do that you won't get to those
learnings so if you tried something and
you've failed and you know and and this
is not for everyone right yes so okay so
it does what about what you're doing
with the Korean startups that are coming
here what are the kind of sort of
conceptual ideas that maybe they bring
in that are different than a startup
here
so we have conducted eight or nine times
startup bootcamp in Korea KC and
as I mentioned there is a preparation
stage but the most important thing for
the Korean startup entrepreneurs before
they come we got a profile how we got to
change my sets switching gears you know
just to to understand the Silicon Valley
ecosystem how you just do the network
how you do business in Silicon Valley
how you meet the participate in the
local you know just ecosystems with that
without that most of I mean last five
years there is about thousands of
thousands Korean startups came into
Silicon Valley and then and this was
they just in the complete a mission
and never coming back again so this is a
fundamental issue I think most of the
Koreans you know just having a problem
seeing a notice a big picture or
different kind I just like the passage
in a in a Silicon Valley so on the
course I think that for everybody and
certainly Americans are like this too
you know we're kind of a big island
country and you're more it's more stress
it's harder to work in a foreign
environment than it is to work in your
own native environment right that's just
a fact
so once how do you see this developing
out do you see young people who are more
interested or are we really is this kind
of always going to be a very small group
out of all the people who are doing
entrepreneurship who are really
interested in this kind of international
global approach
I think the group is small right now but
the numbers show and you know the growth
projections show that that's changing
very rapidly
and you know if you thought the world
was flat ten years ago I mean just you
know look now I mean you know what right
I could Instagram a picture and you know
send it to my family overseas and you
know instantaneously I mean so you know
same thing is happening with Payment
Solutions you know so a lot of the
friction globally
is is you know getting suppressed right
so it's making it easier people have
more access to data from overseas and
you know more people have traveled there
you know so so I think it's definitely
obvious so you had a comment on this
like though I definitely see a huge
train in this I think especially the
Millennial one one they don't want to
wait until they retire to explore the
world they really want to just get
himself there and then they have a very
different style of experiencing new
culture and new life and potentially
even move their professional work around
that so basically I'm seeing an
increasing number of location
independent entrepreneurs and with that
kind of lifestyle they can a lot more
easily take advantage of the resources
from other parts of the worlds and
basically other ecosystem so I I'm
seeing an increasing interest in
basically people moving around to Asia
to Latin America to Europe a lot of my
friends here in the valley they still
treat this as a very important center
because this is still the mecca for
investors a lot of activities a lot of
ideas but increasingly people will spend
more and more time away from here
partially because you know it's getting
quite expensive to stay here so as an
entrepreneur how do you actually extend
your wrong way so that you can basically
have the most resources to actually buy
the time so that your services are
provided or more products can be
successful and coming back to what you
just mentioned we in terms of how
localization is important a lot of time
we speak about Asia as if to say it's
like a single designation we often
forget how diverse Asia is so
localization is of course the key we
actually kick off our every program with
a cultural orientation our day one is
always cultural orientation so we
actually walk people through to do
business even small cultural nuances can
actually kill a relationship for you
right even how you actually hang over
your business are as cool things as that
if you don't have this kind of aware
and also how to deal with investors over
there what's the differences in terms of
what they think what they're looking for
they're actually really a lot to learn
great comments on this one or so yes of
course very briefly and then you know
just the last five years Korea has you
know just cultivating a startup
ecosystem young people people get into
the more on to the start on their own
startups but basically this driven
behind how this is driven by the
necessity meaning is that they find out
to work and then find the ha you know
just employment through this kind of
government supporting system but
nowadays changes slightly different
picture so most of these days young
generation or entrepreneurs starting a
cydia opportunistic you know just at the
Premiership in Korea so meaning is that
they're seeing the huge opportunities in
the global market places they just
committed themselves so this is a big
change so the number wise there was only
2,000 startups in 2000 year 2000 but as
of today there is about little over
$100,000 seraphs you know just in Korea
in 2017 so there's more and more
youngsters or younger generations you
know just a willing to kind of you know
just committed into the startup on the
enterpreneurship
ecosystem right now okay great let's
open before I saw your hand first yeah
okay I work with a lot of Nordic startup
companies and they're increasingly
looking to Asia and as you would expect
China is you know gets the most
attention so why when maybe the Nordic
entrepreneurs want to go to Taiwan and
set up operations there
as opposed to going into China where I
assume there are more more incubators
and accelerators and all kinds of
programs and missions then they can get
prototypes built overnight and
so how do you compete with that great
question for me is not really about
either or it's probably more of a matter
of time so basically I believe every
place in the world of course we have
some key ecosystems but I believe that
actually for them they are probably a
particular time frame during your
entrepreneurial journey that that place
can add the most value to your startups
so Taiwan as a market as a definition of
course no comparison small however it's
a lot easier to navigate especially when
it comes to doing business in the
Western standard when it comes to IP
protection when it comes to navigating
that ecosystem and being seen then
leverage on the existing infrastructure
and the connections that how many people
have already got with China that's in a
way it's so much easier for a westerner
if they if they're new to Asia it's
actually a great sort of springboard
first yeah okay let's go ahead you
mentioned right that you've run
psychological metrics and your founders
I'd be curious is that so
well we're looking to understand how
they think right how they problem solve
and then in addition to that we compare
the founder so we you know we want to
have at least one full-time founder on
the team so but you know as two or more
people start working together we want to
understand the chemistry behind them
then working together have they had a
previous relationship where they work
together they've had if they have
created previous success that's
obviously a plus but a lot of founders
that come to us brand new they have
never started a company before they're
interested they're excited but they
don't honor take that next step so you
know so these these assessments allow us
to get a little bit more into their head
if you will get to know that several so
here ok you first then you then you ok
this like I'm I'm a student from Indiana
University and
currently I'm working on my own startup
and also I worked with like startups
entrepreneurs in China
I'm originally from China also by
entrepreneurs in this area but I thought
Ark is completely different but for like
working here and also in China they have
a different culture and different
regulations so I'm thinking like very
interesting in the ICR area which where
you just mentioned before is just want
to learn what's the difference
like the entrepreneurs from ASEAN area
yeah the entrepreneurs here in America
yeah host like because I felt like in
Isaiah area there has less regulations
and like more opportunities but less
regulations also means little more risk
so I just want to know yeah so the risk
in any you know just like there's a risk
in a new startup there's a risk in a new
emerging economy right you know so so
but the difference is you know if I were
to compare an entrepreneur in Southeast
Asia with an entrepreneur here I mean as
people we have similar wants and needs
right so so it's important to understand
what those are what is your motivation
for starting a company why right is it
just you want to get rich you know or
you know are you looking at like I spoke
about value addition you know really are
you truly trying to solve a problem and
those are the ones you know when you
find that match where you will you get a
direct hit with you know an actual
problem that exists in the space and you
know an entrepreneur you know you look
at you look at you know a Mesa is a
great example let me say is a payment
solution that is about to become a
technic or in Southeast Asia and you
know they saw the friction that exists
in in payment in the region and you know
you know work through and saw that that
problem and now they're you know they're
expanding like you wouldn't believe
because there's no competition so so so
you really have to understand that but
internal motivations are important but
as people I mean we all want success we
all you know we want we all want similar
things so I would say there are more
similarities than differences if you
will as for as two entrepreneurs in
general you know not just health East
Asia okay good
go ahead the matching on some of these
programs as well as the amount of equity
just as a comparison that would have
been useful in the Tweety regions dr.
Munir with say some of the contributions
from saying Israel or Singapore and they
do the matching success to 106 and
Horner's Oh what kind of business models
to question would be why would a
accelerator or Oregon Soprano come to
you with some going directly to the
program that's your value-add and you
take equity for that oh so that's a case
thank you I just think yourself like so
we we are teaming out where those the
first time Coursera investors who
participate in tips programming the in
creation program which is partially
funded by the government which is more
for to the grant yeah you don't have to
pay back so that's the word that the
government comes into the back of the
program so the once you just working on
the that your own asuras and their
failed in that two years later then you
don't have to pay back you don't have to
negations - oh is it purely fee-based
what you're getting from the startup
companies that come in no so actually uh
our teams in Korea to participate in the
first round initial round of the
investment so that's about $100,000
dollars taking about the ten to fifteen
percent of the equity investment here's
at that time we take a risk because
there is nothing you know just a
tangible assets or more products and
solution is in place but we are
evaluating the pretension the future so
that's the how it works right now also
what see just good let's know what is
your business model yeah so our models
so you know I talked about the pink you
bation program right so which is free no
equity you know no upfront fee which is
really encouraging anyone and everyone
who wants to learn more about startups
to come in as you go through that
eight-week program you you qualify if
you do for the incubation program which
lasts 18 months that's where we take an
equity and we join them our entire team
joins them hands on as co-founders to
help them drive their product and get
them to a point a maturity where they
can graduate from the program with you
know with with a solution that fits the
market so okay
and of course the raising of the VC
funds will allow for follow-on funding
after that yeah so the model is right no
this is completely private yeah yeah
okay
ELISA yeah so in Qatar right now we're
still financially independent from the
government so right now we don't take
any equity is a fee based program
however we're looking into starting with
more and more cross-border deal sourcing
and syndication basically moving into
potentially a funding vehicle as well
for some of the companies that come
through the program we do work closely
with some of the government initiatives
and also accelerators in Taiwan so
basically what we do is that because a
lot of the people who come through our
program they're probably still at the
early stage before they can actually get
qualify into some of the government
programs so but because we're connected
with them
very familiar with the resources that
will be available for them once they're
at the stage where they're ready to get
into either the accelerators or
government programs we do have some very
exciting programs actually from Taiwan
for startup founders especially that's
separate from our organization even
though we are let's move on called we're
running out of time
go ahead talk about trust this is very
important for entrepreneurial learning
and cognition between local versus
global ecosystems because you all are
networked
a blank network approach because global
social survey data shows that each of
the countries you represent that
societal trust in institutions and
others is rather low is like 30 40
percent at maximum and so I would like
you to elaborate do your entrepreneurs
trust local basis more like home bases
where you do operate or do they trust
more and they learn more the global
basis like that become here to Silicon
Valley or somewhere else where would you
bring them and this is what what are
they real motivations and how do you
need overcome this relatively low
societal trust levels in institutions
and in in society thank you that's a
pretty big yes yeah you know I think one
reason somebody chooses the path of
entrepreneurship is because someone else
is not already paying you to do what
your idea is right so there's an
independence there to start with and I
think that in regard to seeing the value
in the program's it's self-evident if
the programs are successful then the
people are putting their trust into the
program I do think it's interesting this
whole question of should you stay
comfortable at home or should you really
challenge yourself because home is not
so great does it really mean that you're
saying home is not so great if you're
trying to go and
do more of a global thing what kind of
comments do you get from the
entrepreneurs in regard to the value of
having worked with your program so I'll
maybe speak first about you know trust
in general I mean yes of course you know
if you're in your home home country you
know you you know the culture you're
familiar so you know building trust a
lot easier but we definitely encourage
people to travel right and as the
younger you are you can travel the
better because as you're formulating
yourself you get a more realistic view
about how the rest of the world works is
so it's one of the reasons for these
programs that it helps the startup
companies achieve trust at their next
stage they've kind of been vetted by
what you're doing or people see a value
in what you're doing
is that part of the function absolutely
okay so they must want that right I mean
that's you okay I think that's such a
deep question we got to just put that
one there oh yeah what future technology
are you guys most passionate about and
you believe in that that has legs to or
the necks to protect 15 20 years quantum
computing can be artificial intelligence
could be whatever and what do you want
your company to be involved in from up
from that technology perspective you can
say that your company was involved in
the legacy of that technology I'll start
with a few area so basically mission
driven is actually one huge area that we
care a lot about so there were actually
a few verticals around that that we have
been basically digging into both in
terms of the events workshops that we
host and also in terms of the
intrapreneurs that we select into the
program so one area specifically is
agriculture technology so how do we feed
the planets using technology and how do
we actually you know like do
better job with our mother earth so
that's one area and of course you know
when it comes to a circular economy both
of these two areas Taiwan actually has a
really strong foundation so agriculture
it's one of our biggest strengths and
together with IOT which is basically a
lot of agriculture technology it's a
combination of those two so we have
already got the backbone of developing
that so that's one circular economy a
lot of people don't realize that in
Taiwan it's actually one of the
strongest Halla area we have like fifty
five percent of recycling rates versus I
think in the States twenty thirty
percent and when we have a lot of
innovative materials say for example in
terms of recycling upcycling so that's
also another area that I personally am
very passionate about of course anything
related to also autonomous driving
mobility that's an area that I kind of
feel like Taiwan used to be a huge part
of Apple supply chain not just Apple
like mobile phones supply chain I see
the next phrase I think it's gonna be a
very important base for anything that's
related to autonomous driving okay so
you know when it comes to technology now
you know we are technology agnostic
obviously right because if you look at
where the region is and you know there's
still got a lot of core basic problems
to solve you know and they've got a long
way to go so so you know we're not
sitting in in Southeast Asia thinking
about how we're gonna go to Mars right
we're trying to figure out you know some
more fundamental things but but when it
comes to technology and the penetration
of technology across the world I mean
yeah I agree
I mean either culture is obviously a
huge area because of just you know if
you look at demographics again and how
they're moving and the growth and the
need that we're gonna have for four
basic grains and proteins you know and
how do we maximize harvesting of our
land I mean no question about it
but you know I would personally love to
see that three and a half or so billion
people are in the world
unbanked rise up and get you know and
you know yeah yeah anticipate be able to
vary based on the war of the world
yes exact so you know so yeah okay John
so we're looking for particular Lee and
autonomous vehicle to college because we
have a very fast kind of close
relationship with the Hyundai Kia Motors
at the same time you know this Korea is
about launching the 5g IRT you know just
interest to mobile connections so
anything related to the mobile mobile
contents that platform and security that
could be very essential and lastly like
they're saying now Korea isn't focused
more to the clean energy technology at
this moment along with the smart smart
CDR technology so that could be you know
just main data means that we are focused
on starting this year and moving forward
okay so that brings us back to me
because this is our final seminar in
this series but this fall the theme of
our series is going to be artificial
intelligence and smart physical systems
so covers pretty much all of this which
is I'm going tried to do with this and
we may look at some big company work
from Asia as well as some startup
company work from Asia because I think
we're seeing an area in which the u.s.
may not be in the lead and thank you all
for coming so many people who've been
regulars this spring we really
appreciate your presence every week and
you're always welcome to bring your
friends Thanks
[Applause]